何番目までポイントをすすんだんでしたかね
36からの  今日はこの他人は怠るが
怠るでしたっけ 我々は怠らないようにいましましょうという項目なんです
で あの 繰り返し申し上げますが
これはあの一つの道徳倫理のリストなんです
で 仏教はもう倫理についてものすごい詳しいというかね
これほど明確に具体的に倫理語られるということは
なかなか人間にはできないんです
ですから 倫理道徳って何なのかというね
ことっていうのは いっぱいもう社会では疑問なんですね
どちらが正しくてどちらが間違っているかということは
そう簡単には整理するということ
することはできなくなっているんです
で まあ仏教はもう何でもはっきりと決めつけて結論を出さす
出してみせるので こちらではこの普通は人間に考えられないほどむず
難しいというかね 普通は考えられないほどの
この道徳的な倫理的なリストを
あの 書いておくんです
それでいろいろカテゴリーに分けてますけど
今日は別なカテゴリーなんですね
で その中で番目はこの怠らないこと
そこでこの経典の主体としては
この怠るということは
もうだいたい人間は一般的に誰でもやっていることで
そんなのはわかっているんだよと
しかし これここで私はこの普通の人々と違って怠らないという
そこにチャレンジして頑張ってしてみるんだという
ですから この自動的に簡単に道徳を守られるということはありえないと
そこは仏教の立場なんです
我々は自動的に感情のままで
気のままで生きていると
悪人になってしまうんです
もう悪い方向へ行ってしまうんです
進化の方向へ行かないんです
堕落するんです ですから
やっぱり頑張らなくてはいけないんですね
努力しなくちゃいけないんですよ
努力すると成長はします
人格は向上します ですから
このいつでもこの努力することが徹底的に必要であると
あの 初期仏教というのは
この救ってもらうという概念にはもう大反対なんです
誰かお偉い方に自分の心を綺麗にしてもらう
救ってもらうというのはありえないと
これものすごい反対なんです
で 一人一人では頑張らなくちゃいけない
これはどうにもならんと
で それはいいかもしれませんだけど
本来は我々の気持ちは努力しない方向へ
怠ける方向へ行ってるんです
だから感情のままできていると
もう確実に自分の気のままで
気持ちのように気持ちに沿って生活すると
もうろくな人間にはならないんです
それがはっきりしているんです
だからこの信仰は嫌なの
そういうわけなんですよ
ただ 自分のことを見ると
誰でも気のままでいるとろくなことないとわかっているんですよ
だいたい誰でもわかっている
なのに何かに期待する
もうパチンコ論理ですよ
いくらあのお金がなくなってもなくなっても
もう大当たりしたらどうするんですかという
で これにチャレンジするんですね
それで持っているお金はなくなっちゃうんですね
パチンコやら競馬やら競輪やら
そういう賭け事っていうのはね
大当たりしたらあんた何かも言うんでしょうかと
大金ではないかと そうやってこの運命にチャレンジするというこの怠け癖があるんで
それも怠けなんです 普通常識で考えれば
金が欲しければ仕事をするしかないでしょうに
そんなのは当たり前 決まっている
事実ですね これ 事実はつまらないんですよ
事実はつまらないんだからと思って
まるっきり嘘を信じて嘘にチャレンジする
嘘にチャレンジしちゃうと何も得るものはないんですよ
だからどこまでそういうバカなことをやってますかと
我々は だから そういうわけで
人間の人生っていうのは一向に幸福にならないということがあるんですよ
嘘にチャレンジ 嘘にチャレンジする
だから競馬でもう大当たりして大金来るんだよっていうことは自分の信仰であって
実際は競馬で儲かって億万長者になった人っていうのはいないんですけど
で 道徳の場合でも 人間の心ですから
この同じ心で人間がこの変なことをやってしまうんです
人間は自分の気持ちに正直に生活すればいいんじゃないんでしょうかと
でも気持ちに正直に生活しちゃうと
ろくな結果にはならないんです
ですから 道徳っていうのは
もうちょっと自分の気持ちにチャレンジしないと
気持ちを抑えるということ
気持ちに打ち勝つということをしなくちゃいけないんですね
これで本当の真の人間になります
そういうことは もう基本的にこの心の働きがあるということは
お釈迦様が知っているんだから
そこをその基本的な背景があって
こういうスタイルでこの経典は続けていくんです
だから道徳 倫理 勉強したいという人にとっては
これは初心者向けのテキストじゃないんです
これは倫理っていうものは何なのかで勉強した
まあ上級の知識ある人々にわかるものなんです
いわゆるこれ以上は倫理は語れないんですよ
で これもなぜならば この結論
決断の最終決断なんです
こちらにあるのは 決断に至る過程は
他の経典にいろいろ説明しているんです
これはもう最終結論のテキストなんです
倫理に対して で それでこの
まあそれから経典の中身の説明に入ります
この他の人々はね 誰でも怠っている
そこで私は怠らないように努力すると
最初に出てくるのは努力という言葉でしたっけ
21ページです  最初は戒めましょうと
それでパマッタパーリ語ではパマッタアッパマッタという言葉なんですね
で このパマッタという言葉は
この仏教では大変な大きな言葉で
このすべての道徳は一言葉の中に入りますよと
だからパマッタという言葉の
全ての道徳でない悪いものは悪は全部入るんですよ
アッパマッタといえば
不放逸といえば 全ての道徳倫理がその一言葉に入るんです
だから頑張る人はアッパマッタに頑張れば
それだけでも道徳は完成します
修行も完成します いろいろ私でも誰でも
このパマーダアッパマーダの解釈はね
その都度その都度解釈のレベル変えちゃうんですよ
そのその経典脈絡に応じて
で これがこの意味だという風には簡単にはちょっと言いにくいんです
まず一番目わかりやすい意味っていうのは
この感情のままで 感情に言われるままに生きていることはパマッタなんです
マッタという この酔っている状態という意味からできている言葉なんですね
酔っ払っている状態 そうすると自分で判断して何かできるわけじゃないんです
麻薬でも何か服用して
それでも酔った状態にいる
その場合はもう自分で生きてるんじゃないんです
その異常現象によって人が生かされちゃうんですね
で この酔った状態っていうのは
どんな人間にもある 我々は何かしようと
何か喋ろう 何かやろうと思っちゃうと
この感情が全て決めるんですよ
理性が決まってくるわけじゃないんです
いつでももう気分で 気持ちで
感情で全て判断して行動するんです
そういう生き方はパマッタの生き方なんです
何か判断する場合は 理性で考えて
善悪を考えて 結果はどうなるでしょうかと予測して
その結果も必要なものかいらんものかと
それも考えて行動しなくちゃいけないんです
例えば 決めたんだからやるぞということもパマッタなんですね
特にこの決めたんだからやるといった言葉を聞いただけでも
やっぱりやらなきゃやらない方がいいんじゃないかということはあるんですよ
やらない方がいいという
気配も見えているのに
決めたんだからやると
それは理屈じゃないんですね
決めたことはやりなさいということは
またちょっと違うんですよ
決めたことだからやりなさいという場合は
もう人の怠けを叩いてるんですよ
決めてるのにもやってないという
それがいいんですけど
決めたんだからやりますよという場合はちょっと危険なんですよ
微妙な言葉ですけどね
決めたんだからやりなさいということと
決めたんだからやりますということと
だからすごい違うんですよ
言葉は微妙なんですけど
そういうことだから この心の中の状況から見ると
私たちはいつでも酔っている状態でいるんですね
だから酔った状態でこの感情に我々は支配されているんですね
感情っていうのはいつでも理屈じゃないんです
感情にはまるっきり理屈はないんです
これが好きという場合は
なんでと聞いても理屈はない
これが嫌いというと なんで嫌いですかと
全然理屈はないんですよ
この理屈 論理ないものっていうのは
なかなか解説もできないんですよ
ものすごく粘り強いんですね
だからこの感情っていうのはものすごい質が悪くて
人間の心に もうどんな人間の心もものすごく住み着いてますけど
これ取り払うということはそう簡単なものでもないんです
もし論理的な原因があって成り立った感情だったら
それほど難しくない それは良くないとわかったらすぐなくなっちゃうんですね
だから人間というのは感情で欲
怒り 憎しみ 嫉妬 あれよあれたくさんありますけど
この感情で生きている
この感情の命令のままで生きていることは
奴隷みたいに生きていることで
だから言われるんだからやっているという無責任な生き方なんですよ
怒りが自分で言うんですよ
あれやれ これやれと そうするとやってしまうんですね
本人も弁解する時でも
しょうがないではない
その時私は怒っていたんだからと
言うと もう責任は自分に責任ないということまで言っちゃうんですね
しょうがないんじゃない
あれ私が欲しかったんだから
[笑い]という理屈を持っていくんですね
だからそれは理屈ではないんです
それはただ弁解するだけのことで
弁解しようとして責任がないということを言っているんですよ
やったことに しかし 感情に侵されて何かやっても責任があるんです
で そこは仏教は明確に言っているところ
例えば自分を殺されかける
かけている もう怖くて怯えてしょうがないんですね
激しい感情 怯えという
それで相手を殺しちゃう
あ 正当防衛でそれで大丈夫やという
世間が言ってるでしょ？ではありません
それも感情なんです 感情で人を殺してしまったんだから
まあしょうがないんではないかと言って責任がないということは仏教は認めません
だから世の中で だから道徳はないんですよ
ある殺しは正当化する
ある殺しはとんでもない
良くないという 何ででしょうかと
例えば個人的に人が人を殺したら
ものすごい悪いと 殺人だと
悪人だと あの人はあまりにも怒りやら欲の感情で頭がおかしくなっちゃって人を殺してもとんでもないことだと言って
その人はもう裁くんですよ
しかし 今起きている殺人とかね
世の中で これ正当化しているんです
爆弾を落としても正しいと
我々のすごい軍事力があるんではないかと
世界で誰にもないぐらいのハイテクの殺人兵器持っているんではないか
精密にこの誘導ミサイル持っているんでしょうと
ただその自慢で人を殺したりして
それでお金がなくなるんだから
あなた方も参戦しなさいよと
お金くれと 戦争反対するのは腰抜けやということまで言って
それ人殺しは正当化する
だから大量人殺しは正しくて
一人が一人を殺すことは悪いという理屈でしょ
だから そういう人々に道徳を教えてくれると
人権 権利やらね あれやこれやと教えてくれると
この世界は成り立たないんですよ
だから 常に歴史の中で人間というのは
大量殺人はいつでも正当化してきたんです
兵隊さんが行って人を殺すのは正しい
それで兵隊二人同士で怒って喧嘩して殺しちゃうと
それは殺人 そんな そんなのあるんですかと
そういうわけで このそういう曖昧な
どうにもならない ものすごく曖昧なおかしい非道徳は道徳だということは仏教ではないんです
仏教いうのは普遍的な真理で
科学的な真理で 感情でやるということは何でもよくない
感情自体が非論理的で理性的ではありません
そこで感情でやることは何だかんだで間違っている
一概に間違っている 欲でも怒りでも嫉妬でも落ち込みでも何でもいいんですよ
舞い上がりでも高慢でも
すべて感情です 私は力強いだそうとかね
誰にも負けんそうとかね
そういう高慢的な感情も感情です
誰にも負けんそうと言って人を殴ったり殺したりするの理屈ですかね
それは理屈ではないんです
だからこの感情で生きるということがパマッタという放逸的な怠る生き方なんです
その感情に打ち勝つんです
怒りが出ても 欲が出ても
理性で行動する 怒りが命令することはやりなさいと
これ言いなさいと と命令することは本当にやっていいのかということは理性で判断する
その努力が道徳なんです
それで結果として悪いことをしない結果にはなります
この業というものがあるんだからね
カルマというものは カルマっていうのは
エネルギーにはそれなりの結果があるんだよというね
これには人間は関係ないんです
エネルギーの法則ですからね
行為には結果がある 物質的な行為にも物質的な結果がある
精神的な行為にも精神的な結果がある
これはどうにもならないことなんです
因果法則っていうのは
そちらでは個人の好みとか何一つも関係ないんですよ
太陽がバンバンと光り始めてあると暖かくなるという
というぐらいの話ですよ
だから因果法則の世界から見ると
この感情で行為をしたっても
行為には結果があるんですよ
これどうすることもできないんです
だからあまりにも怒って
もう怒りに狂って もう何も右も左もわからなくなっちゃって
人殺しちゃったんだから
まあしょうがないよ その場合はとかね
というのはもういい加減な愚か者の言葉であって
しょうがないでもしょうがあるでも何の関係もない
もう行為には結果がある
だから正当防衛なんかはないんです
正しい戦争なんかはないんです
行為と結果で行為と結果で見なくちゃいけない
イラク人の石油はイラク人のものであって
それは他の国が取っちゃうとそれは盗みであって
以前が独裁者でしたと言ったっても
そういう理屈は成り立たないんです
だからこのちゃんと道徳世の中であるならば
世の中はすごく平和で豊かになるはずなんですよ
で いろいろ世の中のことを考えたんですけど
このダイヤとかね いっぱい出る国々
アフリカにありますよ
ものすごい残酷なんだよね
生き方が マスシンのどん底で
もう子供たちも手がない足がないとかね
もう殺されたり 爆弾 鉄砲で撃たれたりとか
ダイヤのために あのテレビで見たんですけど
色々村とか全部もう破壊しちゃって
家の中まで掘って 強引にダイヤ持っていく
そこで家に住んでいる人はみんな殺しちゃうんです
逃げちゃうと逃げたっても足が１本ないとかね
手がなくなったと 両手もないちっちゃな子供たち
それで金のある人々はすごく威張って
もうダイヤのネックレスやダイヤの指輪とかね
身につけたりする もし高いお金ダイヤ買うならば
それは作る人々にもお金いくらかいってほしいでしょうに
ダイヤが掘れる国だったら
その国は豊かになってほしいです
なるのは普通でしょうに
でも逆で 貧困のどん底
もう殺されっぱなしで
石油あるんだったらこれ豊かになるの決まってるでしょうに
でもネッツ バファリンぐらいの薬もない
ほんのもう五十円の薬で治る病気なのに
子供たちは死んでいく
それが正当化してますよ
世界は 正しいと だからそれはどういうことかというと
やっぱり金はいくらあってもいいと
それは力ある人はもうとにかくもう世界中の財産はもう自分でも独り占めにすると
これはまあ競争の原理だからしょうがないではないかと
競争の原理じゃなくて
それは欲の原理でしょうに
力あるんだったら奪ってもいいという話でしょうに
だからこういう全て感情の世界で
全て悪そのものなんです
だからこの どんな人間でもこうやってタマーダで生きている
怠って生きている それで私たちもみんなやってるんだから
もう そんな黙っていられませんと
というのは愚か者の考え方で
それでどんどん苦しみが増えるだけで
ですから みんなやっているんだからこそやらないんだよと
それこそ人間だよというのがブッダの立場なんです
だからこの 時代遅れで現代社会に合適をしない
くだらない話じゃないんです
現代人にはあまりにも原始的だからわからないだけ
あまりにも無知で ブッダのこの等々心理は
だからお釈迦様も他の経典で言ってるのは
ブッダの教えはもし世界で表に来るならば
それ以上考えられる幸福ってないんだと
もし教えがもう後ろに行っちゃうと
それで世界はもう不幸のどん底やと
ブッダが現れることこそ
人類にとってこの上のない幸福ですよと
そういうのは単なる宗教家の感情的なスローガンではないんです
全て一つも スローガンないんです
仏教に ただ事実淡々と言っているだけで
ですから この そういうところでこの考えてほしいのは
このタマーダっていうのは感情で
ただ何も努力しないでそのまんまで生きていること
一番簡単にわかりやすい解釈です
酔った状態で生きている
自分では判断しない 怒りがやれと言ったらやる
欲がやりなさいと言ったらやっちゃうという
憎しみがやりなさいと言うとやる
約束したんだからやるんだと言ったら
もうこれ感情です それパマーダの一つの定義で
またいくつかあります
ヴィパッサナー瞑想でもパマーダという言葉を使います
その場合は 今 ただ今の瞬間に気づかないことをパマーダと言うんですね
今の瞬間に 実際に存在する
あるのは今の瞬間だけなんです
ただ今の瞬間だけなんです
ちょっと前の瞬間はもう終わったんです
次の瞬間はまだ現れて生まれてないんです
だから過去の瞬間も将来の瞬間も実際しない
存在しない 具体的にあるのはただ今の瞬間だけ
このただ今の瞬間を見ると
事実も真理も全て見えるはずなんです
だからただ今の瞬間を見ないで
あれこれやと考えながら生活する
このあれこれやと考えながら生活する生き方全体にパマーダ
放逸的な生き方です それはもう真理を発見したくて修行する人々に対する定義なんです
道徳的な定義は前の手
感情で生きていること
ですから このレベルに合わせていろいろ定義をしなくちゃいけないんです
一応その２つだけでも覚えておきましょう
で 何でお釈迦様はパマーダ
アッパマーダ言葉っていうのをすごく大事にしたんでしょうかというと
この悟りのポイントなんですね
悟りを開きたいと 煩悩をなくして解脱を体験したいと思うならば
修行はたった一つ アッパマーダになることだけ
アッパマーダというのは別に難しいことではなくて
ただ今の瞬間を 何をかと観察する
すごく論理的に言えばすごい簡単なことなんです
全然複雑ではないんです
実際にあるのはただ今の瞬間だけということを別にそんなに難しいことではないんですよ
理解するために 過去は終わった
もう再現はしません 将来はまだ現れてもない
生まれてない問題で悩む必要はないし
終わった問題にも悩む必要はないし
だからそこの両端を放っておく
放っておいて ただ今の瞬間は今何でしょうかと
それは観察する その観察する過程で真理が現れてきて
見えてきて 発見できて
心は完全たる解脱を経験する
ですから ブッダの修行方法とは何でしょうかといえば
アッパマーダの実践なんです
ただ今の瞬間 観察する人には
もう感情っていうのは現れてこないんです
過去のことを考えると感情が現れてくるんです
だから道徳も完璧に守られているんです
そういうことですから
このパマーダはすごいこの要になる
すべての道徳の要になる言葉なんです
次の言葉は この他人は確信を持っていない人々ですが
我々は確信を持つようにと勧めますということです
戒めましょうということ
えーと パーレ アッサッダハ バヴィッサンティ マヤ メッタ サッダハ バヴィッサミーティ サッレコー 카라니요
まあサッダハ 確信と訳しています
アッサッダハはもう確信していないというね
で 伝統的にはサッダハは信仰というふうには訳しますけど
これ信仰ではありません
確信ということなんですね
人間には信仰っていうのあるんですよ
それずっともうあって
人々は悩まされるんですよ
ありがたいことじゃないんです
信仰っていうのは ただ信じると
これでひどい目に遭うんですよ
マスコミの話を信じるとか
ひどい目に遭わせる で
名前だけではジャーナリストといえば立派な職業ですけど
本当に立派なジャーナリストっていうのは少ないんです
みんなまあ自分のニュース流れれば自分に大金来るんだから
そういうところで出してくるニュースは強引に合成する
あの あれ何でしたっけ？あの女性の名前はジェシカ？ ジェシカ・リンチさん
リンチ ああいう風な話で
それはあまり一回だけ流せば終わったでしょうに
どれほど人々に嘘を言うかと
アメリカ軍隊にイラクの科学者が電話かけて
このジェシカさんを連れて行ってくださいと
病院にいるんだよと 行ったところで軍隊が来てドラマをやって
テレビカメラであれこれ撮影して
もう書くは書くは書くはエピソードストーリーとかね
あれ書いた連中 いまだにジャーナリストと威張ってるでしょ
書く瞬間で 作る瞬間で
でももうヤラセでインチキでね
もう全地球の人類を騙すためということあるでしょうに
処刑にするんだったら
そういう連中を先に処刑にした方がいいんですよ
別に私は処刑を認める人間ではありませんだけど
そういうことでどれほど人が死にますかね
そういう風にもうインチキ
ありもしない事実を流されると
だから全然どうってことないんです
処刑したっても 人を殺したっても一人二人ぐらいでしょうに
だからこの私たちの状態っていうのは
やっぱり信じるというね
あるいは CNN やとかなんとか言ったら
あ そうですかと もうもうそれを信じちゃうんです
だから こういう何でも信じるということで
かなり人類がずっと昔から今まで苦しんできたんですよ
で これ今出したのはちょっと一つの例だけで
微妙に至るところに信仰が働いているんです
そういうことで 結構我々はまあダメージを受ける
で 信仰で何が見えるかというと
なんで信じるんですかね
あれも怠けなんですよ
自分で考えればどうですかと
[笑い]だからどこかで我々はこの動物と同じ生き方をしたいんですね
誰かに管理されて リードされて
命令されて はい みんな右へ曲げて下さい
右に回って はい 進んでください
進んで はい 止まってください
止まって という生き方が楽だと
そういう性格があるんですね
だから信仰はもう全然人の心からは消えません
それある限り足元は危ないんです
だから神を信じるところから痛い痛いのは飛んでいけという信仰まで
全てもう信仰なんですね
だから試しに我々いる
これは知っているか 信じているかということをチェックしてチェック入れてみると
どれほど自分の人生が信仰に操られているかと
よくたまに騙された 裏切られたとか言うでしょうに
もう信仰のせいなんですね
騙されたとすごく怒って落ち込んだりして
裏切れたと それで落ち込んで引っ込んじゃって
何年も苦労したりするでしょうに
自分が悪いんですよ テレビでまた番組やったんですけど
なんかある人がなんか十年
十五年も夫は自分を騙して裏切って騙していたんだと
どこかで子供作っちゃって
それでかなり激しく憤りを感じたりと言っても
やっぱり夫が悪いとか言ったって
もうあんたが悪いということなんですよ
夫が悪いって解決はないでしょうに
だからすぐに信頼 信仰できる人を探してるんです
再婚するために だからやっぱり信じる
信仰するっていうことは決していいことじゃないんです
で まあ決していいことではないんだけど
まあ危険と言えない ほんの少々はありますよ
例えば 相手が自分のことを本当に心配している
相手が正直に 真面目に
真剣に自分のことを心配している
我が命のように その場合はその人のことを信じても
それに危険になるということはない可能性はあります
その人言うことをやっても
その人言うことを信じておいたっても
なぜかというその人は自分のことは完全に心配している
問題はそんな人っているんですかって
この世の中に 結局は誰でも我が命は一番可愛いでしょうに
みんなの心配っていうのは
自分の命を守るために道具になるならば
相手のことは心配する
だからこれはすごいわがままで
頼りにならないんですね
だから何一つも頼りにならないという風にした方が一番いいんですよ
夫を信じているんだぞと言っても
自分が夫の役に立ってる間は
もう夫は自分のことは心配する
夫には何の役にも立たない状態になっちゃうと捨てられます
親が子供をすごく心配していると言ったっても
それは子供が自分に喜びやら楽しみやら与えてくれるならば
子供のことは心配する
喜び 楽しみじゃなくても
自分にとってはとてつもない不幸
与えてくるならば捨てられます
そういうことですから
なかなか信じられる人っていうのは世の中でいないんですよ
それが生きづらいんですよ
誰も信じないで生きていられますかね
だからどれほど信仰 我々の人生に関わっているかっていうことなんです
では シミュレーションしてみてください
誰一人も信頼しないと
自分が飼っている犬猫あるならば
それでも信頼しないんだと
犬も可愛くなってくるのは
餌をあげて可愛がってあげてるんだからでしょうと
だから信頼できないんだと
誰一人も信頼しないというシミュレーションしてみると
どれほど生きることはきついかと
わかると思います でも答えは
だから人を信じなさいということじゃないんです
私は言いたいのは そこまで我々の人生に信仰がかかってるんです
関わり持ってるんです
不可欠なものになっているんです
ということは 我々はもう鬼の口の中で生きてるんですよ
人食い鬼 鬼がいるとしてください
人食い鬼の鬼の口の中にいて
暖かくていいなとか思ったっても食べられますよ
だからこの信じる信仰っていうのは
人間にとってはもう不可欠なエネルギー
生きるためのエネルギーになってますけど
これがもう猛毒で危険で
鬼の口の中で生きているような感じなんです
だからもうこういう不幸になる
ひどい目になる 裏切られる
騙されるというのは もうそっちゅうもう人間にはあるんです
どれほど騙されるかというと
このいろんな国の情報開示
もう解放しなさいという運動あるでしょ
で アメリカだったら年か年かも時間経ったら情報は出してくれる
年経って情報を見たっても
どうったこともう過去の過去だからもう何の意味もない
でもそれでも読んでみるともう信じられないんですよ
ここまで嘘を言って悪いことするのかと
そこで今言ってることは絶対もう国家秘密だからといって言わない
同じことでしょ 年経ってあの情報を出してくれと言ったらちゃんと出してくれるんだから
その時は昔のおじいさんたちはよく騙されていたんだよという話だけになるだけ
今の自分たちも騙されてるんですけど
だから だからこの政治的な世界を見たっても
一度もなんかいいことっていうのはない
誰かのために我々は使用されているだけ
そういうことだから この信仰っていうのは大変なことで
もうずっと騙されっぱなし
誰かのために我々は使用されていて
家畜動物ですよ 信仰すると
家畜動物は餌もらいますよ
でも太ったら食べられますけどね
親切にはしてくれますけどね
ニワトリでもね 寒くもない
ずっと二十四時間暖かいところで
すごい餌をあげて無菌状態で育ててるでしょ
幸せですね ニワトリたちは
もう半年経つと もう全部もう処分されてもう食べられますから
結局人間の生き方ってのはそういう風になってます
理由は この信仰 信じるということでやられているんです
そんなこと言ったって
もう誰一人も信じないで
飼ってる犬猫のことさえも信じないで生きていられるかと
これまた生きていられないんですね
だからどうすればいいんですかね
なんで仏教ではいっそでも仏法僧信じなさいよと堂々と言うんですかね
仏教の世界では三経は基本基準で
それは心に入らない人々にはだいたい教えてはあげますけど
仲間には入れません そういうことなんです
どういうことかというと
やっぱり人間にとっては生きていられないんですよ
どうすればいいかということをわからないんですね
誰かに聞かないと だから誰にも聞くなよと
自分の道をブッダに聞きなさい
なぜかというと ブッダはもう極端に完璧に完全に慈しみ
憐れみを持ってるんです
一片の見返りも期待してないんです
人々から なぜならば ブッダには要りません
何一つ 自分では完全たる悟り解脱を得ているんだから
人間は何の関係もない
なのに心配するんだから
経典で最近読みましたけど
ブッダの慈悲って何なのかっていうね
説明を聞いてみるともう驚くんですよ
本当に私にも これなりに
これはすごいことやと
だからブッダの心配っていうのは
母親が子供にもしないんです
それよりもものすごい純粋な
強烈に生命のことを心配する
であるならば 分からなくてもブッダのことを聞けば徹底的に幸福になるはずなんです
だからお釈迦様にはブッダを信仰するんだったら
その人々は何の不幸もないんだよと
法華経でもそういう偈はあります
ブッダに帰依しただけでも
その人の人生はそれで危険からはもう免れてますよと
で 信仰するということは
自分で分かってないということも決まってるんです
ブッダに帰依したんだから
仏法僧を帰依したんだからといって
仏教は全部わかっていると
とんだ冗談です それは
だからブッダのサランガッチャムと言っただけで
まあ仏教を知り尽くしてる立派な人やと
そんなことない わかってないんだから
やってるものね しかし
その場合は自分が判断に迫られたところで
どうしようか 困ったなと思ったところで
いつでもお釈迦様は答え出してるんです
自衛隊派遣に賛成するべきか
反対するべきかと 困ったな
これで アメリカは一番親しい友人ですからとかね
いろいろ悩んだりするでしょ
悩む必要ないんだ 人殺しは良くないと
はっきりしているんだから
人助けはとてもいいことやと
だったら復興に行くのはいいんだけど
なんで軍隊が武器を持って軍隊の肩書きで行くんですかと
軍隊は軍隊の肩書きで行くっていうことは戦いに行くっていうことなんです
だったらやっぱり人殺しは良くない
賛成しちゃうと自分も人殺しに参加したことになる
例えば軍隊行動っていうのは国民の行動だからね
国民は鉄砲を持って人殺しに行かないんだから
我々はプロを雇ってるんです
皆様は税金払って 私の代わりに殺してくれと
だから ある国の軍隊がどこかへ行って人殺したんだからといって
国民はいいね やつらやと
単純じゃないんですよ
法則は 因果法則 軍隊っていうのは国民がお金払って雇ってる殺し屋なんですよ
プロの だから旗振って送ったところで
もし向こうはもう自分の命を守らなくちゃいけないし
もし誰かに殺されるようになったところで撃つでしょうに
当たり前だから 撃ったところで相手が死んじゃうでしょ
それで旗を振った人の口座にもちゃんと振り込んでます
後で文句を言って 「私は何も悪いことしていないのに
なんで不幸になってるんでしょうか」と文句を言ったっても
これは愚か者だから知らないだけで
結構口座が残高がいっぱいあるんです
だからこの微妙にでも不注意でも罪は犯せないんですよ
ブッダを信仰すると 考えてください
我々は不注意でどれほど罪を犯しているかということを
なんで私はこの歴史的にも人間の殺しにすっごくもうものすごい偏見的にまで悪口を言うかというと
そういうことなんです
もうちょっと中立的に喋ってもいいんだけど
そのことになってくると中立ではないんです
はっきりとこの悪はダメという立場になって喋るんですよ
それはもうブッダの教えだから
不注意でも我々はもう罪に汚染される可能性あります
そこまで気をつけると
人間の心っていうのは綺麗に保たれますよ
ただ旗を振ってあげても
これも気をつけると でも帰って無事で何事もなく
イラク人を移動とか掘ってあげて
電力をつけてあげて みんなに何か役に立つことをして帰ってちょうだいというのは
別にそれは清らかな希望で
何事も起こらんようにと
と希望するのは立派で
で まあそこまでは期待してないんですね
やっぱり身を張って威張ってやりたいでしょ
それは悪そのまま  それは皆様
現代の今の今の今日の問題だから言ったんですけど
ついつい我々はね 真理知らないんだから結構やってしまうんですよ
悪いことっていうのは
でも知らないんだからわからないでしょうに
誰も本当のこと言ってくれないでしょうに
いまだに説明ないですよ
なんで自衛隊派遣するのかという
批判ばっかりするんじゃないよと
もう泣き入りするだけでしょうに
皆様方の偉大なるリーダーは説明何もしないで
だからこの やっぱり我々は知らないんですね
一般国民は それで知らないうちに罪を犯す可能性もある
そういうことだから どうやって自分の人生清らかで幸福になるように保つかというと
誰かを信じなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
だったらこの世の中の人間は信じるんじゃないんです
そういうわけで 唯一仏法僧しか信じることはなくなっちゃうんです
だったら神様を信じたっても同じことではないかということになるでしょ
キリスト教の方々は だからどれほど人を信じるんですかね
神様のおかげで だから絶対的な愛というものを教えてないんですね
神様は 私を信じなさい
私を褒め立てなさいと言った上で喋ってるんです
信じなかったら だったら処分するぞと
しっかりしてるでしょう
だからこの世の中では信頼しないで生きていられませんというならば
仏法僧を信じるしかないんです
それで信仰になるということになりますけど
その中でもお釈迦様は信仰になるのは良くない
たとえ仏法僧でも盲信で強信で
これが良くない それがまた悪になるんです
強信しちゃうと自分たちが正しくて
他の人々は間違っていて
もうもう直したくなっちゃうんですよ
それでまた人をいじめたり
いろんなことを起こる可能性あります
それは禁止しているんです
それでなぜかなぜでしょうかということを勉強して理解して信じると
その場合は確信なんですね
だから理由は言って 仏法僧を信じなさい
帰依しなさいと信じなさいではなくてね
で 仏教の場合は ブッダの話を聞いて聞いて聞いていく途中で自分が納得いっちゃうんですね
なるほど これが真理だと納得いったことに信仰と呼ぶんです
ただ信じることじゃないんです
だから納得いってない場合はもう気をつけた方がいいんです
危ないんです ただ言われるんだから
お母さんがやってるんだからだったら危ないんです
お母さんもお父さんも仏法僧を信仰しているんだから
私に言われるんだから
小さいところから慣れているんだよという場合はもう危ない
あんなのは ですから この一人一人がやっぱりブッダって何者かとね
何を教えたんでしょうかと
よく勉強して 自分で理解していくと納得いくんですよ
納得いかないはずがないんです
言ってることは全て事実
真理ですからね 納得いったところで
やっとお釈迦様おっしゃってるサッダカ信というものは生まれてくる
だから確信は理性的 信仰は理性的ではないんです
信仰はもうものすごく足が引っ張られて
どんな落とし穴に落とせるか
落とすかわからない 落とされるかわからない
確信の場合はそういうことではありません
それで人類は誰見ても我々信仰で生きてるんですよ
これがやりやすいし 感情的で
あの人言うことなら信じますよという話でしょうしね
それでそれをやめて確信を育てる
こちらでは信仰はないということに確信はないということでね
書いてますけど 次のポイントに行きます
他人は悪を恥じないが
我々は悪を恥じるように戒めましょうと
で これ道徳は恥じる 恥じないという 2つなんですね
で 何を恥じるべきかというと
やっぱり悪いことは恥ずかしいと
そういう気分にならなくちゃいけないんですよ
ああ 恥ずかしいと かっこ悪いんだと
情けないんだと 悪いことはものすごいダサいし
かっこ悪いという風に本気になるならば
もうすごく立派な人間になります
これもすごくおかしいところがあるんですよ
世の中で悪いことを勇気というふうに言ってらっしゃいます
勇気あるんですよと よく調べてみてください
勇気がある 活発的でよく頑張るとかね
と言った場合はほとんど悪いことなんです
ですから この悪いことに際してはもう恥と思わないと
道徳は守れません で それでつなげて 39番目はもう恐れということ
恐れも必要なんです 恥と恐れが
何を恐れるかというと悪いことを恐れる
世の中でまた恐れは知らないことが勇気だと言っている
そんなことではありません
だからみんな恐れはなくなってとか言って悪いことにチャレンジする
怯えるなよと ビクビクするなよと
世界はそういう世界だから
お釈迦様ははっきりと悪いことを恐れなさいと
もし自分が気が弱いんだったら
悪いことに際してはすごく気が弱くなった方がいいんです
恥ずかしくて何もできないんだったら
悪いことをしないことに恥ずかしくなった方がいいんです
それでこの恥ずかしくなることと怯える怖くなることというのは
仏教はこの道徳の世界で使用しているんです
これもお釈迦様は強引に作った概念じゃないんです
事実です あるいはこの世の中はどうやって統一させられるいるんでしょうかと
いくらが世の中っていうのはそれなりに
でしょ 無法国家じゃないでしょ
無法国家になっても どこかで人間はそれなりにまとめて管理されている
それは何なのかと聞かれるところで
この慚愧ですね 仏教用語で言えば
で 恥とその怖がること
恐れること それは恥と恐れだよと
車 昔の車には車輪 2つですよ
この この馬車やら牛車やらね
で 車輪といったっても
そんなにすごい 技術のハイテクなものではないんだから
車輪があって真ん中穴がありますよ
その穴に車の軸をつけちゃうんですね
軸を つけちゃうと もう車輪は動きますけど
車前に進みますけど 外れちゃうんですよ
そこで昔の牛車の場合は
この車輪に あの真ん中のところにこの穴があって
この軸にも穴があるんです
そこに釘をつけちゃうんです
一つ 釘をつけて車輪を止まってもらう
で あるいはこの軸に釘をつけて穴があって
そちらに釘をつけておく
そうすると車輪がグラグラしても外れることはないんです
止まるんです その釘 2つなければ
その車はもう動きません
1回転したところでもうガチンともう落ちちゃうんです
で お釈迦様はその例えを使っているんです
世の中はこの車の車輪につけている釘
止まり え？服？え？ 先生
車輪があって真ん中に軸がありますよね
四角く それに対してこう集まってますよね
あの肝心なところは確か服っていうこと
だからそれつけるでしょ
車に つけちゃうと外せるでしょ
外せないようにつける釘なんです
くさび  くさび？ くさび
ん？ くさびを打つと車輪が回らなくなる
ストッパーですよね  うん
くさび打ちと車軸にくさび打ち込むと車軸が割れちゃいますから
棒ですよね  棒をつけておくんです
別に車軸にちゃんと穴がありますよ
その穴にストッパーでも何か釘みたいなものはもうちゃんとつけてあるんです
で 車輪は自由に回りますが
あの あの車軸からは落ちません
だからもう車輪 2つの車だったら
このストッパーが 2つ必要です
そういう風にこの世の中でこの恥と恐れというストッパーが 2つあって
世の中なんとか安全だよと
なんとか安全です だから悪いことはやばいと思う人は悪いことしないんですよ
それで我々は安心に生きていられるんですよ
そんなことするもんかと思っちゃうと
万引きとか何ともしないんですよ
それは恥なんですね だから恥と恐れという 2つが世の中何とか守っている
だからこれもまた道徳の基本的な 2つなんです
これ どちらでもワンポイントで大きいぐらいに語ってますよ
この恥恐れ 2つさえ人間にあれば
それで道徳的に完璧ですよ
小さな悪いことでも怖がる
怯える 結果なしには何も起こらないぞ
この世の中で 何をしても結果があるんだから
だから小さな悪いことでも結果が出ますよと
だから怖くなる あるいは恥じる
情けない かっこ悪い そんなこと言ってはいないんだと
この 2つあれば もう人間は立派になります
で 40 今日で終わりますかね
じゃあ早く終わりとしましょう
この項目だけは 40は人々はアッバスって
まあ善覚とは訳しましたけどであるが
我々はよく学ぶバフッステように戒めましょうと
道徳の関係ないように
何と関係あるのかね こんなの
やっぱり仏教とはそれも道徳の一部なんですよ
倫理の一部なんです アッパスとは良くない
バフスとは立派 では 歴史的な意味を言います
で 遠い昔は本なんかはなかったんです
いわゆる物質的な本 中国ではね
あったでしょうと思いますけど
まあインドではそんなに紙の文化ではないんだからね
で そんなに普及していたわけじゃないんです
しかし 知識はもうすごい知識
中国なんかはもう近寄れないほどすごい知識とかどこかありましたし
ヴェーダ聖典にしても
これはすごい古いテキストでしょうに
あれほど膨大な作品なんかはね
どこにもないでしょうに
これはもう紀元前三年あたりだと思ってるんだからね
中国の四千年の歴史とかなんとか言ったってもね
そんなに文学はあるわけじゃないんです
できたものは結構後なんですね
中国の歴史ももうなかなかとんでもない古い立派なものなんですけど
インドも決して負ける文化ではありません
あれほど文化があって
学問があって 本がない
本は普及していない だから
例えばある学者が本を作るということは
自分の頭でその一項目一項目
詩で歌で構成するんですよ
一つずつ構成して そのまま自分で覚えちゃうんですよ
歌一つ 歌で作るんだから
テキストは 古いテキストは全て詩でできているんです
できたところで 自分が一つ二つ目作って
それをそのまま覚えておいて
それに解釈も自分でつけて
それも覚えておいて だから頭の中で本はきちんと具体化的に現れるんです
祖師先生がもしかすると紙で
紙と言ったって葉っぱで書くんですけど
葉っぱに一冊ぐらいは書くかもしれません
書くかもしれません 書いても百人の弟子たちにもコピー一枚一枚ということはありえないんです
コピー一つ作るの大変な作業だから
中国では簡単で もう紙を開発しちゃったんだから
もう掘ってからもう全部刷っちゃえばね
もう楽でしたけどね そこはなかったんですね
その技術は で あのヤシの葉っぱがあります
すごい結構頑丈できついし
そこで書くという 書くと言ったっても葉っぱを削るんですね
だから時間かかる 結構労働
それで勉強する人々は本を持ってないんです
全部聞いて暗記する 先生はテキストをまあ一つ一章ぐらい読み上げると
生徒たちも後からそれは唱えてあげて
それからもうずっと繰り返して
その一日全部暗記する
きちんと暗記したならば
それから一つ一つ解釈してあげたりする
一日中それで勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
ということは よく聞いている人っていうのは
よく勉強している人っていうことになるんです
だからバフッスータの意味は
スータっていうのは聞いている
今でもいろんな話をよくたくさん聞いているということは
よく勉強しているという意味でしょうしね
今本ですから たくさんの本を読んでいるんだよと言ったら
よく勉強しているということになるんです
とにかくバフッスータ
アッバスータ アッバスータっていうのはもう直訳するとあまり聞いたこと聞いてない
種類のことしか聞いてない
バフッスータというのは大量に物のことを聞いている
聞いただけでは何の意味もないんですけど
昔の聞くということはちゃんと理解して勉強するという意味ですからね
だからこれは学問のことなんです
現代的に言えば 善学か新学かというね
善学  うん 善学とバフッスータといえば何言えばもう
博学ですか  博学 善学か博学かという
これは仏教はね 道徳のリストに入れてるってこと面白いでしょうね
これはすごい特色です
道徳の一つですよ 嘘言ってはいけないとかね
人のものを取ってはいけないんだよとかね
いうことと同じく よく勉強しなくちゃいけないんだよと
だから勉強しないっていうことは
仏教から見ればものすごい非道徳的なことなんです
それはすごい特色ですよ
だからお釈迦様そう言ってるんだから
もう明らかにこれはもう道徳です
人間として立派に生きるために
品格よく正しく幸福に生きるためには必要な条件でしょうに
あれこれと勉強する いろんなことを情報をよく理解して勉強して
またあらゆる技術も腕も磨いておいて
ごく一般的な当たり前の道徳やとこんなの
だから学問は道徳にしているということは
道徳っていうのはすごい単純なんです
人間であるならば もう守るのは当たり前なんですよ
道徳さえ守れないんだったらね
もう人間とは言えないでしょうに
だからそんなに学問に対してごちゃごちゃ言う必要はないんですよ
勉強っていうのはそんな難しいことでもないんですよ
みんな学問はもう命みたいな感じで偉そうに考えてるんだから
そんなことじゃないんですよ
やれば誰にでもできますよ
あまりにも大げさに考えすぎなんです
勉強 どなたかにはこのインターネットでも見てくださいと言ったら
やっぱり私たちの年ではとか何とか言われたんですけど
それは何のこともないんだよと
そんなのは だから今の年ではインターネットいじったりとか
もうどうかなとか そんなことはないんです
すごい単純です ものすごい単純です
だからそんなのも基本的な道徳はやっぱり嘘ついてはいけないというぐらいのものなんですよ
いろんなことを勉強する必要なもの
だからあの 勉強したくないと言った時点でもう罪を犯してるんですよ
誰かを生命を殺したとかね
万引きしたっていうこともすごい悪いことでしょうに
それで自分の人生がもう不幸になるでしょうに
万引きに体が慣れてしまっちゃうと
もうスイスイスイスイ病気になるでしょ
最近テレビでまた女の人の見たんですけど
もうどうしようもならないのに
もうすぐやるんだと 万引きしたものは必要が全部もうただそのまま家であちこち積み重ねてるだけで
お金がなくて 食べ物がなくてやったわけでもないんです
何かつまらなくなったりして
それでやりだしちゃって
あ これ刺激的だなと思って
もうずっとやってやっても止まらない
やめたいんだと その女の子は言うんですよ
私はこんなことやめたいんだと
でも見たらすぐもう何でもいいんだから持ってくるという
だからこれが病気になる
世界はこの人殺しやら他の殺しやらいじめることやら空き巣に入ることやらね
そういうものは道徳ではないとか何とか言うだけで
勉強しないことも道徳なんですよ
非道徳的な生き方なんです
だから学校に行きたくないと子供が言うと
これも罪なんですね 今の学校の教育なんかは
もうなんでそんなやらなくてもいいんではないかと
そんな言う必要ないんです
そんなのは役に立たない
立てないんではないかとかね
もう何でもいいんだから
むちゃむちゃいろいろ勉強した方が人生すごく明るくなる
で 仏教は勉強したんだからと言って頭が良くなると思ってないんだからね
それも覚えておいてください
ブッダが説く智慧は別なものです
あんなのは基本的な道徳の一つなんです
だから学校に行けない人やら勉強しない人と明らかに不幸になっているでしょうに
この世界で不幸になったっていうことは
悪業をやっているんだからでしょ
だからそこが大事なポイントなんです
いろんなことを聞いて
聖書でもコーランでも何でもいいんだよ
どうでもいい なんだかんだでまあむちゃくちゃ読めばいいんです
読んで知っておく それで結構自信もついて明るくなります
ですから学校っていうのはある一つの組織ですから
それに行く行かないかっていうことを置いておいても
行かなくても勉強 することだけはもうとことんやらなくちゃいけない
それぐらいのことで それで世の中の人々は浅学であるというのはね
本当にそうでしょうかと
やっぱり人間っていうのは早くも勉強終わりたいという気持ちでしょ
勉強するんですけど 養老さん言ってるように
やっぱり早くも壁作りたいんですよ
だから医療ミスやら政治家平気で起こるんです
壁作ってはいけないんです
普段はなんとか何とか勉強して
なんとか何とか大学出て
これでもう終わり これで一生食べていくぞということになる
するでしょ これがすごい危険です
訓練するものだったら
そっちを訓練しなくちゃいけない
磨かなくちゃいけない
勉強でもずっともう読み直さなくちゃいけない
しかし 世界はそうじゃないんです １
冊本読んだだけで これはもう読んだ
もう終わりましたという感じで
知ってるんだぞという態度を取るんです
これが結構危険でしょ
特に医療ミスなんかは
そういう知り知ったかぶりというか
知ってるんだぞという高慢から出てくる問題です
学生の時は教えてあげたあらゆる注意をずっともう気をつけて
それからいつでも自分の知識を磨いて磨いて磨いて
いろんな情報を自分の頭に入れて
いつでも知識はね 最新な最新的なレベルで持っていかないとどうなるかっていうのはもうわからない
どこかで失敗する だから世の中の人間っていうのは勉強するんだけど
どこかですぐもうそこでストップしたいんですよ
まあこれで十分というね
仕事のためにはそれで十分かもしれませんだけど
やっぱりそれでも常に磨いて磨いて磨いて
いつでも上手に使える状態に置いておかなくちゃいけない
これ 壁を作ってはいけないんですね
バカの壁という壁は これが誰でも人間作っちゃうんです
そういうことだから 世の中の人々は浅学であって
私たちは浅学にならんように頑張るんではないかということで
道徳的に持ってくるんです
で 番目は怠けることですね
人間は怠け者であると言うと
なんか機嫌が悪くなるでしょうね
我々は怠け者じゃないとかね
やっぱりお釈迦様から見れば
みんな怠け者です それ考えたことがありますかね
なんで頑張るんですか
人間は楽をしたいんだからなんです
怠けたいんだからなんです
どうしたことないんですよ
だから努力しても どこかでもう壁作って腰をそこで下ろすんですよ
頭の中 いつでもあるんですよ
どこで腰を下ろすかという
何に頑張っても 心には染みついてますよ
怠けたいということは
そこで怠けたいんだから
みんな頑張ってるんです
これ 仏教から見ればなんかおかしい
子供たちに勉強しなさいと言う時も同じ理屈で言うんですよ
今よく勉強しておけば
あとは楽だよと だから後で怠けるためにちょっと頑張ってくださいと
我慢してくださいと そういうわけで
人間の心には怠けっていうのは確実にある
世間で努力することっていうのは
ただ怠けるためにやっていることであっておかしいんですよ
だから努力する自体はすごく苦しいんですよ
あれは我慢ですね それで我慢して自分が期待するところに行ったら
そこもうやめて そこから怠ける
で これも仏教は道徳の一つで
これだったらもう不幸になるんだからね
で 仏教の世界はアーラッダ・ヴィリヤ
励み精進する アーラッダっていうのは
この切れないって意味なんです Continuous
という続くって意味なんです
一回力絞って踏ん張ってやって
そこで力を抜くっていう意味じゃないんです
いわゆるContinuousという続く努力
努力には停は止はないんだと
で ストップはない 努力っていうはね
これ自分の心の中 怠けたいという気持ちは
なんとかそこで考えてやらないと我慢は良くないんですね
我慢が入ると怠けたいっていうことは確実にあるんです
物事には終わりがないんだからという態度でやらなくちゃいけない
朝ご飯食べてもそれで終わるわけじゃないんですからね
また昼も出てくるんだから
それでまだ終わらないんでしょうに
もう続くんでしょうに
お風呂に入ったんだから出て
それでもう一生いいやということはないでしょうに
世の中見る そうやって終わりがないんですよ
ものは流れるんですね
流れるものに対応することはアーラッダ・ヴィリヤなんです
だから精進には はい ここまで精進すれば十分だよっていうことはないんです
で そういう気持ちになると
本当に道徳的なんですね
怠けないっていうこと
だから我慢という言葉は仏教では良くない言葉で見ていて
精進励むことは正しいこと
それでアーラッダ・ヴィリヤという言葉は使うんですね
アーラッダっていうのは
この途中で諦めない やめないって
続く努力  持続させる  持続する努力続くということで
それから番目はこのサティのことで
このヴィパッサナー瞑想でも使っているサティなんですね
サティとアッパマーダはまた同じものなんです
サティっていうのは気づくことですね
それで反対の言葉は不注意なんですね
不注意で生きている 誰でも不注意で生きている
ただ今の瞬間は何なのかとは気づかないんですね
で 我々は気づきを絶やさないように戒めますと
ただ今の瞬間というのはいつでもあるんだから
気づきはそこまでですよということはありえないんです
いつでもただ今の瞬間だから
これは完全に悟り開くまでやるんです
四十三番目は えーと 他人は無知であるドゥッパンニャが
我々は知恵がそれ何でしたっけ？備わるようにと戒めましょうと
パンニャーサンパンになるように
知恵 だから仏教はこの知恵も一応こちらに入れてますけど
どうせ涅槃まで入れますけどね
で 知恵って何ですかね
勉強すれば知恵が現れるんじゃないんですかね
勉強すればしたんだからで知恵が現れないんです
勉強っていうのは幻想の現象の世界の勉強なんです
これはどれぐらい重いですかとかね
高さはどれぐらいですかとかね
二足す二はどれぐらいですかとかね
真理の勉強じゃないんです
大阪まで距離はどれぐらいですかとかね
何分かかるんでしょうかとかね
それが勉強なんです 現象の世界なんです
真理じゃないんです 大阪まで何分かかるかということ
この時代によって変わるでしょ
五十年前の答え 今は通じないでしょ
だから普遍的な知恵じゃないんです
五十年前で聞いたならば
東京から大阪までどれぐらいかかるかと
一日かかっちゃうって人に
今聞いたら二時間四十分ぐらいだと言っちゃうでしょうね
リニアモーターができたならばね
もっとまた答えが変わっちゃうんです
だから勉強っていうのは普遍的な真理ではありません
時代とともに変わっちゃうんです
だから百年前のいきなりタイムカプセルから百年前の人がすごい知識人が現れてくると
何一つわからなくなっちゃうね
この世の中で 百年前はすごい知識人でしたけどね
いっぱい勉強して 今来たらもうどうにもならなくなっちゃうんです
料理もできなくなっちゃうんですよ
ガスコンロ使い方わからないんだから
電子レンジなんか見たらどうするでしょうかね
だからあれは勉強の世界
だから毎日これ磨かないと時代遅れになるんですよ
だからバフストにはもうずっとやらなくちゃいけない
もう勉強しちゃったぞと思って腰を下ろしちゃうと
それから馬鹿になっていくんです
時代遅れで だから知恵はそれじゃないんです
知恵は普遍的なんです
時代と関係ないんです
いつでも同じものなんです
真理は だから真理を知ることは知恵というんですね
でお釈迦様おっしゃっているのは真理なんです
だから二千五百年前におっしゃったのに
今も何のことなく通じる
ところが人間はもっと遅れているだけ
お釈迦様はそれでも最新的なことを喋っていて
これ恥でしょ 現代人に
現代人の考え方よりはるかに進んでいるんです
これからも進んでいるんです
どんな時代でも ブッダの教えはいつでも先に行っているんです
科学は発展したんだからと
仏教は壊れません ブッダの教えは壊れません
どんな素粒子やらクオークやら何から何まで
量子力学 あれこれとかね
何か出たっても だからブッダの教えは絶対改良してはいけないんです
自分に分からなくても
教えは大事に守って 次の世代に伝えておいた方がいいんです
分からんものは全部削除とかね
そうやったんだから 仏教はもう堕落しちゃったんですよ
日本の社会から仏教が消えたのはそういうわけで
もう改良してやろうではないかと
だからこういうひどい目に遭っているんです
もしちゃんと仏教を純粋に守ったならば
もう日本はもう大国になりますよ
アメリカには負けないと思いますけど
だからもうすごい力ですよ
仏教のブッダの教えっていうのは
負けません どこに行っても
今はいつでも電話かけて
アメリカからどうします
どうしますと聞くでしょ？逆になるんですよ
ブッシュさんがもしかするとイラクを潰したくなったならば
これもうこれの方が儲かりそうとかね
次の選挙で勝てそうと
本当ならば もしかすると日本が仏教の国だったら
向こうは電話かけて そういう考え方もありますけど
あんたどう思いますかと
こちらはもうバカだからやめなさい
そんなことはとはっきり言えるんです
やめなかったら他の国々と一緒になってあんた方を潰してやるぞと
それぐらい力がつくんです
で なぜかというと どんな論理でもブッダの論理は勝ちますから
通じます人間に もう世界でも仏教はないんだから
すごい悲しい状態にはなっている
みんなが弱い状態になっている
ブッダの教えは真理であって
普遍的であって変わらない
学校で勉強するものは
あんた何年卒業生ですかと聞かないと
だから年 の卒業生と年の卒業生っていうのは違うんです
しかし 何年卒業しても
それに学問を磨いておけば大丈夫ですけど
だからこちらでは智慧ということが言っているのは
智慧というのは普遍的な真理ですね
だから仏教で言ってますからね
全てものは無常ですよとか
因果法則だよと 実体はないんだよと
人生はつまらないんだと
虚しいんだと 空・住・滅・道やらね
無常・無我・苦やらね
そんなもんです 真理っていうのは
因果法則 それで終わり
パンニャーは それ以外何もないんです
一切は因果法則で 原因があって現れる
原因が壊れたらすぐ潰れてしまう
だから全ての物事は無常である
実体はない だから人生トータル的に見るとくだらない
無意味ですと そんな振って遊んだってもね
あんた方は幸福になれんぞと
どこかで苦しみが付いてるんだと
別な世界で平安と安らぎとあるんだと
心はちょっと変えると
というぐらいのことは智慧と言うんですよ
で 心にこの貪瞋痴がなくなることが智慧というんですね
また別な定義で これ我々永遠に苦しませているのは貪瞋痴なんですね
これ取っ払っちゃうと智慧です
で それに頑張る 番目は他人は自分の主観に取り憑かれ
しがみつき 捨てられないでいるが
我々は自分の主観にとらわれず
しがみつくことなく簡単に捨てられるように戒めますと
これはこの解脱についての道徳なんです
この性格あれば悟れます
これがないと悟れません
だからこれが最後の道徳です
なんかすごい単純に聞こえるでしょうに
単純じゃないんです 人間というのは何か知ったら
あ 知ったぞと思ったら
もう取っているんです
それは そこから逃げられなくなります
[笑い]進歩はなくなっちゃうんです
何でも捨てないと 何でもその時間だけで正しいでしょ
時間の中で だから 100年前の科学っていうのは正しかったんだけど
100年前では 今は正しくないんですよ
だから100年前の科学の本を読んで
それにしがみついちゃうと
誰も科学者だと認めませんよ
私たちは何か知ったらそこにしがみついちゃうんですね
捨てられなくなるんですね
これがもう人間の不幸の元で
争いの元で 輪廻にしがみつく
脱出できない そういうことなんです
ですから 何であろうとポイポイともう新しい情報入ると捨てるんです
その性格あれば瞑想で悟りまで進むんです
何か捕まっちゃうと 瞑想でも同じところでぐるぐるぐるぐる回ってるんです
自分にとっては瞑想で全然進歩はないんだというならば
原因はここです 何か捕まってずっと握っているんです
捨てないといかんです
お釈迦さんの例えが言ってます
言った例えがありまして
昔は牛なんかはね 外で飼いますから
だいたいこの時々この鎖じゃなくてロープで牛を杭ね
縛っておくんですよ ロープはいくらか長いんですけど
そこら辺である葉っぱ草の牛が食べる
食べて牛が退屈だな ちょっと散歩しようかなと思ったりするんですよ
散歩しますよ でも散歩をしてもロープの長さの中なんです
それでちょっと休もうかなとか休んだってその中なんです
では餌を探して食おうではないかとか
新しい餌とか言ったっても
その中にある餌しか食べられないです
だから何かにしがみつくと
もうそれでもう運命は決まってるんだと
そういうことだから 進歩なくなりますので
悟るためには これは最後の道徳
で 一番最初に言ったものは
もしかすると簡単かもしれませんだけど
この 44番目はものすごい大変なことになるんです
でも聞き聞こえが軽々ですよ
でも軽々くはないんです
これは人間の豊かなんです
例えばもう意見に執着するなよと
あんなそんなのは簡単に単純でしょうと
ではなくて それがとても難しいことなんです
世間はそうじゃない どんなものにもすっごく執着しているんです
だから悟ってないでしょうに
そうじゃなかったら もうとっくに悟っているはずなんです
瞬時に悟っているんです
悟れます 悟りがどんどんどんどん遠くなるのは
どれくらいこの杭に縛られているかということで
仏教はとことんもう勉強すると
ロープがちょっとちょっと
もうもうちょっと 1メートルぐらい伸ばしてあげようということになるかもしれませんだけど
あの解放してくれることはないんです
だから仏教徒はかなり幅広い視野で世の中を見ていますよ
差別はないし みんなに慈しみを育てるし
結構心が大きいんだけど
だからって悟っているわけじゃないんです
ただ ロープは長いだけ
アッラーこそ神様やと思ったら
もうじっともうそこにすべってて
もう殺されちゃうんですね
もう大体杭の側に首絞め縛ったということは
これから殺されるということなんです
だからかなりロープは長いということは
まだまだまあ大丈夫ですね
他の宗教と仏教の違うところはそれだけロープは長いんだよ
こちらは お釈迦様が言うのはこれダメやと
執着するものを いろんな意見に厳密に粘りついて執着することはやめなさいと
それやめるともう悟りに至ると
ですから 道徳の最高一番大事なことはそちらにあります
それで項目だけは終わります
例えば 1番目はみんな加害者である
我々は加害者にならないように頑張る
あれが単純ですよ よくわかりやすい
誰も守ってないんだけど
加害者になること偉いと思ってますけど
世間はそれさえも守ってないんです
そこで単純な道徳からどんどんどんどん極端な道徳に行ってくると
これサンディッティ パラマー スヤーダーナ ガヒ ルッパニ サッギということになるんです
で これで経典の一番難しい道徳の説明は終わりましたし
で これは特別な経典なんです
これがこの挙げるためにわざと作っているものなんです
唱えるために みんなで声を出して唱えましょうと
しかし結構長い 唱えようとすると
真面目にフルバージョンで唱えようとすると
もしかするともう二 三時間かかると思います
それでも価値があるんです
例えば昔の人々っていうのは
満月 満月 新月 半月はね
修行するんだから その場合
一日修行にふけるんです
ただ これだけ二回ぐらい読めば
もうほとんど一日終わってますよ
だって食べる時間やらね
いろいろ他の用事もありますからね
でもすごい修行になるんですよ
道徳を唱えることで で
唱えることで この四十四をびっしりと頭の中に留まるんです
覚えられるために いろいろセットセット作ってます
いろんなセットがあるんですけど
全部道徳の四十四項目で合わせているんです
今説明したのは このサッレーコーカラニーヨというパーリの言葉なんです
パーリ語の だから こういう風に唱えるんですよ
パレーヴィヒンサカーバヴィッサンティマヤメッタアヴィヒンサカーバヴィッサンミーティサッレーコーカラニーヨ
一番目の項目 二番目 パレーパーナティパーティーバヴィッサンティマヤメッタパーナティパーターパティヴィラターバヴィッサンミーティサッレーコーカラニーヨ
このサッレーコーカラニーヨという言葉で四十四項目を唱えるんです
ものすごく励みになるんですよ
信じられないほどなんか勇気が湧いてくるんです
しっかりするために サッレーカーっていうことの意味っていうのは
もう真剣にやるぞって意味なんです
すごく注意するんだよと
みんな加害者である しかしここで我々は加害者にならんようにとすっごく気をつけているんだよと
これで四十四も読み上げる
だから読み上げるためにあえて作っている経典です
面白いことは 誰もいろいろ経典を挙げたりするんですけど
伝統の中で これが挙げないんです
人間というのはあべこべですけどね
仏教の人々も そこであの 2番目の道徳セットがある
2番目のセットあります
それからは簡単だと思いますけど
2番目はあのチョンダ長老に言いますけど
チョンダでいいことをしたいなと思っただけでも立派だよと
思っただけでも立派だよと
チョンダよ 私は言います
良いことを行おうという発心だけでも大変効果的です
ということ いいことをしようと思っただけでも
ものすごい立派だよと言って
コーパナワードカーエナワーチャアヌヴィディーヤナース
えーと 何でしたっけ また体で言葉で実践するならば
その利益については言うまでもありません
で お釈迦様は断言して申し上げます
思っただけでもものすごい立派ですと
ものすごい結果があるんだよと
やったらもう言うこともないんだと
言うまでもないんだと
それで励ましてくれるんですよ
頑張れと 背中を叩いてくれるんですよ
この経典で 他の経典なんかかなり落としてますけどね
お釈迦様が でもしかし
この経典はそうじゃないんですよ
みんなを本当に母親みたいな感じで
しきりにしきり応援してくれるんです
だからすごく大変大切な経典です
で こんなに親切に応援してくれるというところはね
そうたくさんは無いんです
それで 2番目のセットで思っただけでも素晴らしいですよ
ましてもうやったならばと
それから 44 また読み上げるんです
だから人々は加害者で
もう他者に害を与えるが
我々は加害者にならないように発心するべきです
じゃあ決めましょう 加害者にならないように言おうではないかと決めましょう
殺生しないように言おうではないかと決めましょう
で その 44 まで行くんです
だから 2番目のセットはそういう風に決めましょう
チットッパーデータッパン
それから 3番目のリストになってくると
ちょっとした例えもあります
なんで繰り返し繰り返しこの 44 項目はこのテキストに入れたかというと
そういうわけなんだから
読む時でも声を上げて読んでほしい
時間があればワンセット読んで
それでやめてもよろしい
また明けて次のセットも時間がある時は声を出して心に読み上げてやる
2番目のセットの決まり文句はパリッカマナーヤということ
例えばとんでもない悪い道がある
それからすごくいい道がある
どんな道で歩くかと 道が 2つです
一つはものすごい悪い道で
もう柱が壊れているかもしれませんし
地雷を踏んでいるかもしれませんし
あるいは目的まで続かない道かもしれませんし
しかし もう一つ きちんとアスファルト引いて信号もあって
もうガードレールもちゃんと付いている立派な道 2つありますと
それで人間は良い道を選ぶべきでしょう
それで私たちはこの不幸になる道をやめて
幸福な幸せな道を選ぶではないかということで
また読み上げるんです
それで道 2つというのは
人々の道 他者加害者の道は殺してでもぶん殴ってでも奪ってでも食って生活しようではないかという世間の世間が行く道
もう一つは釈尊が説いている加害者にならない道
道 2つありますと 一つは平安で安らぎで綺麗にスムーズ繋げる道進む道ですと
そういうことで唱えるんです
道が 2つある そこで私たちは正しい道を選ぶ
どういうことかというと
みんな加害者であるのに
我々は加害者にならんように気をつける
みんな殺生しているのに
我々は殺生しない道を選ぶ
みんな嘘をついているのに
我々は嘘をつかない道を選ぶと
で 道を選ぶという気分
気分で 3番目のセットを読み上げるんです
また  44もそういう風に読み上げてほしい
で ここでこの選ぶということだからね
私はこの選択についていくらか喋っていくことがあると思いますけどね
人間っていうのは選択に困るでしょう
困るなよと これブッダの道を選んでいる世界だから
悩むことは何もない お釈迦様の言う通りやればいいんです
絶対的に言っていることは
どんな本で何書いてあったっても
ブッダが言うことを選ぶ
もう全然迷わず選べていることなんです
これはきちんと正しいんだと
ですから この普通人間っていうのは
どうかなとかね もう悩んだりはしますよ
やってもいいかな やっぱりやめた方がいいかなとかね
問題はない 道が 2つあって
これ選びましょうと それから向上と堕落という二言葉に
あるいは退化と えーと
何て言ったっけ 進化 退化と進化がありますと
向上と堕落がありますと
どちらにする？はっきりしているでしょうに
向上を選ぶでしょうに
進化を選ぶでしょうに
それで それにまた道徳リストを入れるんです
退化する道がある 進化する道がある
堕落する道がある 向上する道がある
そこで私たちはみんな堕落している
堕落の道を選んでいるのに
私はもうブッダの教え聞いて向上する道を選ぶと言って
この 44 をまた読み上げる
そうやってこの道徳を守る
守れるような人格をどんどん
あの 育ててもらうんです
この気持ちを それぐらい難しいんですよ
そう言わないと人間の心を道徳に入れ替えることが
もう本来悪ですよ もう黒いんです
灰色じゃないんです ものすごい厳密に黒い
だからこれ真っ白い心にすることだから
これぐらいやらないとね
だからこれは全部応援なんですね
これ 3番 4番目のセット
で これでまあもうこれから皆様に一人でお読みになると思いますけど
大体 42 ページのところは
で これもこの現代大乗仏教までにも言ってる一言葉ですけどね
だからこのちょうど自分が泥の沼に溺れていて
他の人はね 泥の沼から
吹き焼けるっていうのはありえないんだと
この救済は否定しますよ
仏教は 君らを救ってやるぞ
だから観音様っていうのはいるはずもないんです
自分で悟らないでしょうに
悟らないで人々を救ってやるぞと
大きな嘘ですけど だからこの特にあの初期大乗仏教の世界というか
この伝統的に僕も初期仏教に悪口言ってます
初期仏教っていうのは
この自分だけのね もう悟りしか考えてないんだとかね
我々はそうではなく 他者の悟りのために頑張るぞと
そういうインチキ一つ嘘一つ作って
すーっとどんな学者の本でも
大乗と他の仏教の本たくさんあるでしょ
みんな同じ理屈なんですね
どこで学者かと 学者っていうのは物事を新しく発見する連中でしょうに
ただ 誰か間違ったらすーっと大事に
その間違ったことだけは言い伝える
アメリカの報道機関と同じなんですね
ブッシュは明らかに嘘を言ったら
これは何とかして正しいと言ってやるぞと
次から次へとニュースを工場で作る
だからそういうやり方っていうのは良くないんです
だから この言いたがりのこれなんですね
あの初期仏教とか 浄土仏教というのは
この一人だけ 私だけ悟ればいいやと
あなた方のことを知らんぞというね
そんな話っていうのは普通は世の中でないでしょうに
言うはずもないでしょうに
私だけ良ければいいと
それはイスラム教の人でも言わんでしょうに
まして たとえ浄土であろうとも
仏教は言うはずないでしょうに
現にもうテロでやっているあの過激であれは何かやってる自爆までするイスラム教さえもそんなことは言ってないんだから
これ人間はあまり言わない
その気持ちあっても なのに堂々と浄土仏教はそんな教えて言う
この あの 何て言いますか
これ訴えというかね もう
どれほど根拠ないかというと
それをそのまま次々論文にも書く
学者の方々もね どれほど無知
無反 無批判 非学問的かというとね
信じられないんです だから好き勝手に他人の悪口を言うんじゃないんですよ
もう で 言ってもその理屈は成り立たない
お釈迦様は論理的に自分が溺れていて
もうあんた助けてやろうと
助けられないでしょうに
だから人を助けたければ
自分がしっかりしたところに足を入れて助けるんです
なんでこれ水にしなかった？泥の沼っていうのはものすごい怖いんですよ
水よりも わざと泥の沼にしているんです
水だったら泳ぐこともできるんですけど
泥の沼やらもう一つ あまり日本人には私も経験ないんですけど
あれなんとかありません？あれ地獄
あれ 地獄みたいな この
底なし沼  うん クイックサンドというね
まあちょっとでも入っちゃうと
もう終わり 人間でもね
そこいろんなところにあるみたいですけど
日本ではないんですけどね
ちょっとでも体揺らしちゃうと
するとまた中に入っちゃうんです
水だったらもうなんとか浮くことできる
浮くこともできないんです
だからそんなものに入ってる人はどうやって助けるかというと
やっぱりそこに行かないで
外から硬いと地面にいて
手を伸ばすなりに何か入れるなりにロープを投げるなりに
それからもう引っ張らなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからお釈迦様は自分が怒りっぱなしで人に怒るなよと言っても
誰が聞くんですかね 怒ってはあかんぞと
聞かないでしょうに 自分が欲に溺れても
あんた欲張り良くないんだよと言っても
もうかっこ悪いというと
もう そういう理屈で頑張っちゃうんですよ
もうこの仏教を改良した世界は良くないんですよ
だから矛盾だらけで もう説得力はないわ
じわじわと壊れていくわ
文化になったら文化は一応もう誰でも守りますからね
それでなんとか守られているだけ
宗教は関係ないんだから
文化の場合はね 別な宗教のものでも
年の古いもの  2000年古いものだったらありがたく守るでしょう
それで文化遺産で守られているだけには威張るなよと言いたいんですけどね
本当にもう生きてる人間の心できていないと
いつでももう貶されますけど
初期仏教は未だに人間の心の中で生きている
そんな己だけ良ければいいんだったらね
もうそういう国々でもすぐバカにされるでしょうに
テーラワーダ出家してと自分だけ悟ってさえいればいいやと思うんだったら
我々に頼ると思いますか？一般人は
相当頼ってますけど お坊さんたちが堕落すると信者さんがすごく困るんです
怒鳴るんです 怒るんです
なんででしょうかね 勝手にしろと言えばいいでしょうに
そうじゃないんですよ
俺で困るんだよと あんた好き勝手な悪いことしちゃうと
だからアリー・ラナというサローデという福祉のやってる人がいて
これ結構有名な人で 別所厚生会で彼に何とか平和
何とか賞とかなんとかくれたんですね
いろんな国々からこの平和賞あれ賞とかもらってる人で
で こちらに来たら彼が講演してたんですね
で 有名な人で いろんな国々でよくＮＨＫでも長い番組があってね
彼をハイライトしてね
インドネシアの村の開発
いろいろそういうことに協力することに
このだからその国際的な人なんですね
彼がこちらに来て講演で何を言ったかというと
スリランカの仏教は大乗仏教ですと
堂々と言ったみたい そこで別所厚生会も大乗仏教の組織ですから
みんなすごく喜んで なるほど
あの国も大乗仏教ですかと
私にもおかしい もう初めて聞きました
あんたの国もね 大乗仏教
それですごい親切ですね
私に帰って で まあ昔から別所厚生会といろいろもういろいろ縁がありましたからね
別にぶつかることはなかったんですけど
で 私はわかってないなと
こう言ってることは それがすごいんです
あのスリランカの人も
で 自分は大乗仏教の人ではないし
もう宗教と関係なく福祉やってますから
カトリックやいろいろ宗教とも仲良くやって
それで明らかに新興宗教組織からね
かなりの大金の賞なんかをもらったところで
その人々を褒めなくちゃいけないでしょうし
だからといって真実をまげたくはないし
見事に行って帰ったんです
どういうことかというと
大乗仏教っていうのは
すべて人々を救うことでしょ
みんなに役に立つことでしょ
それはやってますからね
いまだに だったら本当の大乗って誰ですかという話なんです
言ってるのはあんた方は口先だけやということなんですよ
でもそれが読み取れないんです
だから有坂さんが別に悪いことを言ってるわけじゃなくて
私もやっぱりこれがポイントだとね
それは言うべき あ なるほど
こういう風に言ったらよかったなと私は思ったんです
後で で 時々ね 我々大乗仏教と言えば
そうです 我々も大乗仏教ですと
ああ よかったと で  どういう風に大乗仏教って
私たちはやっぱり人々のために
一般信者さんのために一生懸命頑張ってますよと
うるさいほど ということになりますからね
ですから この まあそれは余計な話で
こちらではそういう話はもう大丈夫あった世界でもなかったんだから
この自分がだらしない状態でいて
人は直すということはできない
だから 人々のために人々を救いたければ
もうこの道しかないんだよという意味でこれ持っていくんですね
だから自分で悟ることもなく
智慧を開発することもなく
何もしないで人にお説教というのは
これは迷惑ですね そういうことだから
また読み上げるんですよ
うん で 次にはこの被害
加害者たちには害を与えないっていう仕事はあるんじゃないんですかね
救いのために 安らぎのために
嘘をつく人には嘘をつかないということがあるんじゃないんですか
安らぎのために だから自分の幸福のために
他人の幸福のために そういう道があるでしょうと
ということで 四十四もう一度読み上げて
それで涅槃まで入りますから
それでだいたい終わりますね
それで何回何回も繰り返してみると
この最後は最後です 自分でやらないと何にもなりませんと
人のためにもなりませんと
自分で悪いことをすると自分がすごく苦しいんです
自分だけですかね 悪いことすると苦しいのは
周りも被害者たちは？嘘を言う私はすごく苦しいんです
嘘を言わなきゃいけないという
とんでもない嫌な状態にはめられているんだから
嘘を聞かされて騙されている人々は幸せですかね
その人々の不幸でしょうに
だから悪いことをするということは
自分も炎に燃えていて
他人にも他人も燃やしちゃうんですよ
それで そういう燃えることをなくなって平和になるために
あるんじゃないか 道はということ
こちらで言っているのは
あなたは今加害者であろうとも
あなたに道があるんだよ
加害者にならないっていうこと
あんた今嘘つきかもしれませんだけど
あなたには幸せな道があるだよ
嘘をつかないっていうこと
あんた殺生するかもしれませんだけど
あんたにも平和な道があるんだよ
殺生しないことでっていう
そういうことで 自分が今唱えている自分が今すごい悪い人間であろうとも
ここで励ましてくれる
あなたの道がありますよと
今燃えていても もう燃えない安らけの道ありますよということで
最終的に唱えて経典終わっちゃうんです